GOOD AFTERNOON
AT ONE DON'T HAVE A GAVEL BUT-
THERE'S A. TO ORDER HERE OF
THIS AFTERNOON AND- RAINY AND
THUNDEROUS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IRONICALLY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA MY UNDERSTANDING AS
WE ARE RED FLAG WARNINGS AND
OTHER WEATHER'S CLEARLY
DIFFERENT AND PERHAPS. IN
SOMEWHERE FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
WHICH. I TO MY MIND OVER TIME
THAT I'VE BEEN IN THE FAMILY
THAT HAS BEEN ONE PERFORMING
AGENCIES THAT WAY OVER STE AND
WE DON'T HAVE A RIGHT WORKFORCE.
IS IN THAT BUT THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED. AT FIVE I'VE BEEN
FORTUNATE OVER THE COURSE OF
THAT AND TWO SO THE BIT OF A
DEBT TO ME. ERIN THAT'S SO WHY
WERE HAPPY. BUT THIS TODAY IS
TO NOW THIS REPORT TECHNICALLY
ON THE IS. OF REAL ID. BUT ALSO
TO YOU ARE WELCOME. CORD ONLY
BEEN. BUT I THINK IS ABSENT
FIVE. INFORMATION FOR ON THE
PATH. I'M. WE'LL ALSO HEAR FROM
CARE TO TELL A CEO OF A-
WARNING WAS GOING TO DISCUSS.
THE VERY REAL. WE HAVE AN
IMPACT FROM THE BILL I THE
DEVIL. HOW THAT MIGHT AFFECT-
TOURISM THE ECONOMY OF THE
STATE. FEDERAL REAL ID ACT WAS
PASSED. SOME TIME AGO TWO FIVE
DRIVER THEN I CAR I DID GET
OURS NOW HAVE TO MEET CERTAIN
STANDARDS IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
BE EX TO BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. OFFICIAL PER. WHAT
KIND OF OFFICIAL PURPOSE TWELVE
ACCESSING MOST FACILITIES WERE.
IMPORTANT TO UGH UGH CONSUMERS
BOARDING FEDERALLY REGULATED
COMMERCIAL AIRCRAFT AND THAT
BEGINS SO A ELEVEN MONTHS FROM
NOW ON OCTOBER FIRST. AS OF
AUGUST TWENTY NINETEEN IN A
MOTOR VEHICLES IS ASSESSED
ABOUT FIVE AND A HALF. IN REAL
LIFE THESE- UP. AND THAT NUMBER
BECAUSE WE CAN COUNT THE PEOPLE
HAVE COME THROUGH THE VARIOUS
OFFICES BUT- IT'S ANTICIPATED
THAT WE WILL NEED TO PROCESS
AND ELEVEN MILLION BY THAT OCT.
TWENTY AND MY UNDERSTAND.
ESTIMATE BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE EXACT UP OR IS IT
MIGHT BE SO AND TODAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF WHAT GOES HAS
KEPT WAIT TIME- I SHOULD SAY IN
RECENT WEEKS THE DEPARTMENT IS
WAIT TIMES. OF MY- BY ADDING A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER. FIELD
OFFICES YEAH AND BY MAKING THIS
PROCESS. THEN OF REMAIN
RELATIVELY STATIC AND AS THAT
NUMBER ROOM INSTEAD THE NUMBER
OF IDEAS THAT HAVE PROCESSED AS
WE GET CLOSER TO THE DEADLINE.
AND PROCESSING THE BEFORE THAT
DEADLINE BECOMES MORE AND MORE
PROBLEMATIC. SO IT'S VERY
LIKELY THAT OTHER WILL CROSS.
FORTY IS WANT TO NEED A REAL.
TWENTY HOPEFULLY TODAY AND IN
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY REQUEST
WILL HEAR WHAT THAT STEP.
VEHICLE INTENDS TO TAKE. TO A
KIND OF EXTREME WHAT IS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IN AND RECORD.
I'M GOING TO GIVE MY COLLEAGUE
HELLO AS REST. COME HERE ALL
THE WAY THE BEAUTIFUL AND LET.
THEM RIGHT THERE TO IT'S
RAINING. BORING EARLY EARLY
THIS MORNING AND WE HAD HAIL
AND REALLY UNDER- A COUPLE
HOURS. I THINK IT MUST BE
HEADED IN OUR DIRECTION BUT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE BEING HERE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES CHAIR OF SUB
THREE- ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RICHARD BLOOM ALWAYS GO TO
HEARINGS. ONE WAS IN SAN
BERNADINO I THINK IF I CAN GO
TO SANDRA DAY BYE SIR CAN COME
TO LOS ANGELES AS WELL. BILL
IDEA. THIS IS OF AMERICANS
DON'T HAVE A REAL IDEA- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS HOLDING US
BACK WE DO HAVE QUITE A FEW
THAT HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED- WE
KNOW IT STAFFING ISSUE AND
THEN- THE LEADERSHIP OF A SOME.
BLOOM WE PROVIDE IT FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED. ALREADY BEEN. THEIR
JOB OF JULY OF THIS YEAR AND IT
WORKS I THINK THE SECOND PART
OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT. THE LOSS OF. OVER THE IN
THE ECONOMY BECAUSE OF. ONE OF
THE ESTIMATES. THEY ESTIMATE
THAT AT LEAST SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TRAVEL.
COULD BE TURNED AWAY BY TSA
CHECKPOINT ON THE FIRST DATE
COSTING THE ENEMY FORTY THREE.
CONTINUE WE'RE LOOKING AT HALF
A MILLION DOLLARS IN DOLLARS-
DEPENDING ON HOW LONG IT TAKES
TO EVERYBODY IN THERE. ANOTHER.
INTERESTING IS THAT OR HALF OF
CALIFORNIA. DON'T EVEN KNOW. TO
BE COMPLY AND TO BY OCTOBER OF
NEXT YEAR US THERE'S LOTS OF
WORK DONE ON PLAN. BUT YOU CAN
YOU CAN COUNT. THE MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE WI HELP CALIFORNIA BE IN
COMPLIANCE SHOULD THE WE DON'T
HAVE THE ECONOMIC. THERE WE
HAVE OUR CALIFORNIANS
COMPLAINTS. HAVING. SET UP IS
REALLY IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT-
MISTER BLOOM LOOKED ABOUT THAT-
HAVING PROPER NUMBER OF STAFF
TWO OF THE NEED PEOPLE. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT WE WILL.
AT TODAY'S HEARING AND I AM
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE. THANK
AND NOW WE'LL TURN TO. AND
SINCE FOR YOU ASKED I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS YOUR FIRST TO
AN ASTORIA. IS THERE A LITTLE
SKIN COLOR WE HAVE TO. WE WANT.
THIS WHOLE. THIS IS THIS IS MY
FIRST OFFICIAL AREAS OF THANK
YOU ARE WELL FOR THE NICE WARM
WELCOME AND THE GIRL AT THE
GROWING BEGIN. MAYBE IT AB
BARBECUE APPS BUT SO WHAT GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND THAT. UPS. I'D LIKE WELCOME
LOSE IT REVERSED WHO IS ALSO
PART OF. SUBCOMMITTEE DID YOU
HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU DIRECTOR.
THEY'RE THE SAME. OKAY SO THIS
ONE BETTER MY TRAVEL YEAH. TOM
C. HORTON ON THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES
AS- IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR AS.
YOU MIGHT HEAR. SERVICES THEY
SHOULD EXPECT US. THIS MY LONG
TERM VISION FOR THE DMV PHASER
CURRENT CRISIS AS SHORTFALLS IN.
WE DO ESTIMATED AT. WE WILL
CLOSE. WE DO AGREE THAT THE
OTHER SOMEWHERE AROUND SIXTY
MILLION PEOPLE THAT SHOULD HAVE
A REAL DEBATE. WE ARE ABOUT SIX
NINE. IN THAT IN THAT PROCESS
TODAY. AND IF WE HAVE A LITTLE
OVER FOUR THOUSAND OR ISSUE WE
PER MONTH IS A KEY THE ISSUANCE
CONTINUE TO CORPUS NEEDS OF THE
TOTAL POPULATION SO MORE PEOPLE
ARE GETTING A REAL ID BUT
STILL. CHALLENGE FOR ME
AWARENESS AND- ACTION TALK
ABOUT I'M SURE DURING OUR
DISCUSSION THANK. IN ORDER
INCREASE THE RELY THE- SAYS
THERE'S A NUMBER. OFFICE HOURS
ARE MAKING SURE THEY'RE OPEN
THEIR THEIR. SHE CAN'T TO MAKE
OUR WAY OF THE NEED RELY THE-
ACTION- CAM AWARENESS REALLY
CAMPAIGNS ARE VERY SPECIFIC DO
SOMETHING NOW WE WANT TO
SPECIFIC OR WE CAN BE. THE
TAKEN ACTION TODAY THAT THEY
MIGHT TAKE THREE OR FOUR. SO WE
CAN TRY TO TRY PEOPLE INTO.
NUMBER DRIVE THE DRIVE OF THE
OFFICIAL OF THE PROCESS HAVING
SOME. FIELD OFFICES AND WATCH
RELATED TAXES HAPPEN. AND I
WOULD JUST SAY IS WASTED TIME
SOCIETAL TIME ECONOMIC TIME
PEOPLE WATCHING US TYPE ENGINE
SOME SO WE'VE MADE SOME SEE.
CLIENT THE. TWENTY MINUTES INTO
IN OUR PILOT FACILITY HELP 265%
REDUCTION. I'M NOT A ROLLOUT
STABLE BUILD. MEET TIME
IMPROVES WAIT TIME WHEN HE. THE
JUST NEED AS WE TRY TO PULL
THEM FORTY. WE'RE DOING THINGS
OUT TRYING TO SHIFT TRACK. TO
ALTERNATE SO WE TALK ABOUT
THOSE WE HAVE AN UNDER UTILIZED.
BUSINESS PARTNERS ARE TRYING.
TO CHIEF TRAFFIC TO THOSE TO ME.
THE SPACE IS AVAILABLE WELL IN
THE IN THE DMV. TRANSPARENT
COMEDIES STRATEGIES THAT WERE
REALLY DRIVE PEOPLE INTO THE
WINDOW MAKES ME PEOPLE WHO. YOU
IN I GUESS FOR ADDITIONAL
ESTUDIANTE TO THE WEAPONS ON AS
WE WOULD ALL BE. THOSE CHANNELS
OF IT CAN BE SURE THAT HE WOULD
BE SER BY ANY OTHER BUSINESS
OTHER THAN PERHAPS THE STATE.
WHEN IT'S- FRESH AND PRESSED.
QUESTION SO THERE'S A HECK OF A
LOT OF TIME TO WRITE UP A TO
THE DEMAND THE DO YOU HAVE A
PROJECTION OF HOW MANY. SERVER
FOR OVER THE COMING MONTHS
SLIPPED. WHAT IT FOR- BEING
ABLE TO WHAT WHAT WHAT CAN YOU
TELL US ABOUT- HOW LONG DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THE WAIT TIMES TO BE
ARE THEY GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DROP DO YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO NECESSARILY INCREASE BECAUSE
NGUYEN IF I UNDERSTAND THE
NUMBERS. CORRECTLY GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF MONTHS AND THE NUMBER
OF. PEOPLE WHO ARE LEFT TO BE.
PRESUMABLY TO BE SERVED- WERE
GONNA BE FACING AT LEAST A
MINIMUM- DOUBLING OF THE-
PEOPLE IN THE TO BE SERVED
STATEWIDE. RIGHT ON A MONTHLY
BASIS SO. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK HE- THE CHANCE RESUME
IT'S A VERY BASIC MATH PROBLEM
I THINK WE HAVE THE CAPACITY AS
WE REDUCE THE CYCLE TIME OF THE
TRANSACTION SO THE AMOUNT OF
TIME IT TAKES OUT THE WINDOW TO
COMPLETE A TRANSIT AS I
MENTIONED WITH. THE COMING WITH
US PASSPORT TODAY. WE'VE MADE.
THIS TO. TIME FROM TWENTY
EIGHT. TO TEN MINUTES. IF OUR
RESIDENTS CAME OVER THE U. S.
PASSPORT. ALWAYS WHICH IS
COURSE NOT ALWAYS THE CASE BUT
THAT'S RIGHT NOW 50% OF PEOPLE
TEND 2% WITH US PASSPORT. AND
PEOPLE CAME IN AN ORDERLY
FASHION WHICH PEOPLE HUMAN
NATURE TELLS US NOT BEHAVE
ORDERLY. THAT WE WOULD CREATE
ENOUGH CAPACITY WITH THE READ
THAT YOU. GIVEN THE DMV PARTY
THE BUDGETING PROCESS IS. I'M
IS WHERE WE. AND AN ARTIFACT SO
WE NEED A TO BEGIN DRIVE WHERE.
SHE CROSSED MALL JUST.
COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO LOOKING AT
THE DEMOCRATS X. OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES. MESSAGE SENT TO
THE COMMUNITY. ACTION AND WE
WANT TO FILL SOME OF THE
CAPACITY THAT WE'VE OPENED UP
BY REDUCING THE TRANSACTION
CYCLE TIME. BECAUSE NOW WE'VE
CREATED SOME SPACE WHY THE M.
THE WAIT TIMES ARE COMING DOWN
HAS BEEN CREATED. LESS
RESISTANCE LESS FRICTION THE
WINDOW NOW WE NEED TO SERVE WE
FEEL SOME OF THAT NOT NOT TO
MAKE WAIT TIMES GO BEYOND
LEVELS WE HAVE SOME HAS BEEN
ADDED TO FILL SOME ADDITIONAL
TRANSACTION. BROADLY SPEAKING
AT ME WE BELIEVE THAT AS YOU TO
REFINE THAT PROCESS CAN TWENTY
EIGHT DEGREE ANGLE LOWER THAN
THAT IS STILL MEET. A DHL
REQUIREMENTS AND STILL MEET OUR
OBLIGATIONS TO OUR RESIDENTS
BUT- IS IT WE'RE GONNA NEED.
THE MORE PEOPLE INTO THE YES WE
CAN ACTUALLY. TRIED IT SOON
THAT ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION THE
OCTOBER. NOW WE DO NOTHING ELSE
EXISTING WHAT WILL STILL
REQUIRE RETIRE PROBABLY. FOUR
MILLION AT FOUR HUNDRED.
THOUSAND UNITS. THAT STILL
LEAVES A GAP OF EVERYBODY. FIVE
TO SIX PEOPLE IN THE DISTRICT.
AS WE GET CLOSER THE DEADLINE
PEOPLE THAT ARE A LOT OF
PLANNERS ARE STILL GOING TO
SHOW UP. WE WILL CREDIT PASSAGE
OF THE. POTENTIAL NOT BEATING
THAT. GO LASSEN. TALKING ABOUT.
ERNEST K. CAN YOU DESCRIBE A
LITTLE MORE FULLY AND.
COMMERCIALS WHERE THEY WERE IN
A WHERE THE PLAYING AND- WITH
THE IT IS A FOR THOSE. OVERALL
IT'S SOMEWHERE NORTH. MARCH
FOURTH PROMOTED. WE ALSO DO
THINGS ARE WHAT WE DESIGN WHICH
IS. SOMEONE THOUGHT. YOUR COST.
OF OUR PART WEB REDESIGN. SO
WHERE YOU STICK I MEAN TO GIVE.
ADDED TO PACIFIC COMMUNITY
TARTAN. THE TEST IN THE IN
BAKERSFIELD IN OUR ROLLING OUT
TO THESE SMALL A SMALL. MARKETS
WITHIN WITHIN. THE STATE WERE
CAMPAIGNS ARE YOU SEE
BILLBOARDS RADIO ADS AS THE TV
ADS YOU'LL SEE SOCIAL MEDIA OUT
SO WHEN YOU SEARCH FOR REAL
IDEAL. LITTLE TALK ABOUT IT
CALIFORNIA. OUR WERE YOU
PHYSICALLY ARE AND BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THE APPROPRIATE ADD TO
USE A WE DOING A NUMBER OF
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT ARE
TRYING TO GET INTO CAN DRIVE
AWARENESS AND SECONDARY TO
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS GONNA TRY
BACK DRIVE ACTION THE ONE. GOOD
BUT ACTION IS WE REALLY WANT
PEOPLE AND NOT HAVE TO MEET YOU
JUST HOW WE OPERATE FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE THESE THINGS THAT.
GREAT EMPLOYMENT BEFORE THEY
COME IN. BUT WE HAVE CAPACITY
THE OFFICE AND DAILY BASIS WE
WANT ACTUAL DRIVE. YOU CAN MAKE
A POINT. WE AS WE PROGRESS
THROUGH THE NEXT REPUBLICAN ME.
ROBIN ONLY SO WE'LL MOVE THE
OBSTACLE WELL I GOT ON A PLANE
AND AFTER THREE MONTHS WE DON'T
WANT. TO GO. ON THE TIME YOU
WANT TO COME TO THE LEFT ON THE
TIME OF. IF YOU THINK REAL. THE
OFFICE INTO A WE'RE GONNA RUN
AND TEST NUMBER OF THESE
HYPOTHESES HE CAN MAYBE WILL
DRIVE THEM TO AND THEN PRESENT
HIM WITH AN ACTION THEY CAN
TAKE RIGHT NOW HOW HOW DO YOU
MEASURE THE EFFECT OF THE-
AFFAIRS OUTREACH EFFORT. SOME
OF THE COMMISSION SOLDIERS WERE
REALLY LOOK AROUND WE SEEN AN
UPTICK IN TERMS OF WHATEVER THE-
IDEALLY. THIS IS A I MEAN IN
TWO PARTICULAR SITE YOUR
PARTICULAR MICROSITE SEEN
SUBSTANTIAL OPTICS IN IN
PEOPLE'S AGAIN AWARENESS OF
PROP PROSPER. EASY ONLINE FORMS
WHICH ARE DRIVING TO THAT ARE
SPECIFIC SITE GET TO WITH. THIS
SPECIFIC YOUR- IN THE AD
CAMPAIGN SHE MEASURE. ON TOP OF
THAT WORST TEMPS. WELL I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY
FOUND OUT ABOUT WHAT THEY FOUND
OUT ABOUT HOW PREPARED WHERE
THEY DID THE USE THAT HOW DID
THEY RESPOND TO THE MESSAGE OF
TO. HOW ARE PEOPLE RESPONDING
TO THE MESSAGES. NEEDED TO IN
THAT MESS YOU'RE SATISFIED WITH
THE DATA THAT YOU'RE RECEIVING
THROUGH THOSE EFFORTS I AM I
NEED. RARELY SATISFIED WITH
ANYTHING A FEW TO BE HONEST BUT
I THINK WE ARE WE ARE LET'S
JUST WE. BUT I THINK THIS IS
IT'S A- IT'S A MATTER CAST AND-
YOU BELIEVE WE'RE GETTING DATA
THE DATA- WE STILL NEED TO MAKE
IT SAYS MORE DETERMINISTIC
BETWEEN YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
FACT. FACT FOR ME WOULD BE DID
IT COME INTO THE OFFICE WHERE
THE REPAIRED. WERE THEY ABLE TO
DO THAT ONCE. SHIFTING GEARS
SELF FOR A MOMENT. YOU FOR A.
SO FAR FROM MY CHIN FROM. TRISH
FUNDED FOR A. THE INCREASE AND
THE HOW ARE THE HIRING EFFORTS
GO AT. ARE YOU GONNA BE RIGHT
NOW. I BELIEVE. HE SAID LOOK AT
THE BOTH. BUDGET PROCESSES.
WHATEVER THE OFFICIAL STATE
BUDGET STILL SOME NEW DIVING
BUDGET CHANGE PROS ABUSING. WE
LOOK AT BOTH OF THE BUT- THE-
BEEN POVERTY THAT THE DMV I
THINK WERE THE NUMBER I SAW
JUST IMPROPER FOR THE CHANGE.
94% OF. WE NEED TO BE. THE
FRONTLINE IN THE POP PERSONNEL
AND SO ON SO I THINK WE'RE IN
PRETTY GOOD SHAPE IN TERMS OF
RESOURCE WE DO HAVE SOME
ATTRITION IF YOU HAD TO THAT.
WHICH IS NORMAL AND WERE.
RETAIL TOO MANY EXPERT
COMPETING WITH OTHER. WAGES
ARE. ONLY LOW- COMPARE EXITING
THE JOB SO I THINK THE TEAM'S
PRETTY GOOD JOB MY JOB IS TO
HELP. BEING ABLE TO DO THE
THINGS THAT MAKE IT SO THAT WE
TAKE AWAY SOME OF THE- THE VERY
DIFFICULT DRUDGERY THE VERY
ADMINISTRATIVE TO THE TASK. AND
IF WE COULD SIMPLIFY THAT SO
THEY COULD REDUCE COMPLEX. I
THINK OUR- TEMPLATE BE MORE
SATISFIED IN THE JOB STILL IT'S
AS A RETAIL JOB. TEXAS AS
SATISFIES A CAN BE BUT IF WE
TAKE AWAY SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL STEPS THAT. ARE
REALLY SORT OF SACRAMENTO
MANDATE THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT'S REQUIREMENTS I THINK
WE CAN. THEIR EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS I THINK WE WILL
IMPROVE. MORALE TWELVE AND ALSO
GIVEN THE FIELD. HE HAD THE
ABILITY TO. DO I NEED TO GET.
MANAGED BY SACRAMENTO BUT THE
TO ENABLE THEM TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE GOOD AT. ANY THE WAY.
IN THE DMV SENDS OUT. PAPERWORK
TO END OF IT THIS. IS THERE
INCLUDE. FOR THANK URGING
PEOPLE TO GET THEIR REPLY DE
TAKING CARE OF THAT PROVIDE A
CHECKLIST OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT OF. ONE OF THE CALENDAR
HERE IS THAT THIS IS NOT A-
NORMAL VISITS TO THE DMV. AND
IT'S FREE. TO LET YOU HAVE TO
COME AND YOU. DO IT ONLINE- TOP
OF THAT YOU HAVE TO BRING IN
SPECIFIC WORK WITH. HOW ARE YOU
MISSING THAT ISSUE YES WE TRY
TO. INSERTED INTO THE ENVELOPE
SO THINGS WERE SENATOR HOUSE WE
USE THE REAL ESTATE ON THE
ENVELOPE ITSELF PUTTING COLOR.
AS A RECENT FELIDAE CONVERT
MYSELF THE MESSAGES WERE. WELL
YOU CAN GET THIS OR THAT AND
WE'VE CHANGED OUR BY FROM WELL
ALL TO SAY NO WE WANT TO DO
THIS WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO NEED. TO RELY THE- TO
GET A FEDERAL. WE WANT OUR BIAS
IN THEIR PRICE TO BE IF YOU'RE
QUALIFIED FOR. I REALLY DO YOU
SHOULD BE THE COST OF. LEVEL
PRETTY CLOSE TO THE SAME SO WE
WANT TO GET PEOPLE INTO THAT SO
WE'VE CHANGED OUR EVEN OUR
MESSAGING WE PRINT ON ENVELOPES
WITH THE WITH THE THINGS WE
STOP IN THE OFFICE AS WELL AND
WE ALSO HAVE OUR MICROSITE U.
R. L. THAT'S THAT'S EMBEDDED IN
EACH ONE OF THOSE DOCUMENTS SO
WHAT. THOSE HAVE GONE OUT TEAM
THE PATIENT AND IN ACTION. GO
UP SUBSTANTIALLY. IT HAS A AS A
CHECKLIST THESE ARE THE THINGS
YOU DO IN AND IT REALLY START
WITH DO YOU NEED A REAL ID AND
WALKS YOU THROUGH ALL THE STEPS
THE YOUNG THE WHAT GOT ME TO BE
IN CHANGES WERE WERE MAKING
SORT OF AS WE SPEAK IT'LL
HOPEFULLY BE LAUNCHING THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE FROM A PASSIVE YOU NEED A
RELAY THE MESSAGE TO A YOU NEED
A REAL IDE AS AMERICAN ASK YOU
IS A YOU NEED TO REALIZE THE
MEDIA BY THE STATE HERE ARE THE
STEPS. AND IF YOU CONNECT. WITH
THE- ARE YOU READY. WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO TEST A NUMBER OF
HYPOTHESES TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE
PEOPLE. TO ACTION. VERSUS JUST
AWARENESS AND WE THINK THE
ACTION. AND AWARENESS. GO HAND
IN HAND IF WE CAN DRIVE THAT
AWARENESS AND ACTION TOGETHER.
WE CAN DRIVE PEOPLE INTO THE
CURRENT PERIOD. AS OPPOSED TO.
SEPTEMBER THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE
RIGHT APPROACH. TO MAYBE. I
THINK CREATING A SENSE OF. SEE
IS- AT THIS POINT TIME ANYWAY.
YES IT'S GOING TO BE. IMPORTANT
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS A ONE. PIECE
TENSION ADJUSTMENTS RISES TO
SECURITY CARD. BE ABLE TO MY
MIND AND I REMARKED CONNELLY I
KEPT IT ALL THESE YEARS BECAUSE
YOU ARE RARELY CALLED UPON TO
CHOSE PTOSIS THE CARD. ALSO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE. NOW CHANGED
THEIR NAMES. I MEAN I WAS. MY
LOTTERY SO I KNOW PEOPLE WHO.
MORE THAN ONCE OVER THE COURSE
OF FOR. HERE'S WHERE THEY WERE
MARRIED. PEOPLE CHANGED NAMES
JUST BECAUSE- NAME. HAVE A THE
REASON FOR DOING THAT. AND THEN
THAT DOESN'T MATCH UP WITH THE
SERVICES TO THE SOCIAL SIX THE
CARD. HI HOW YOU RESOLVE THOSE
ISSUES. THEY DON'T ALL COME TO
YOUR DESK BUT- THE GENERAL IS
OTHERS. MONTEL THINGS YOU
PRESENT FOR THIS THIRTY
ADMINISTRATION QUALIFICATION IT
JUST HAS TO BE YOUR FULL NINETY
TO SUCH PRETTY NUMBER SO IT
WHETHER IT'S THE STREET CAR
WHETHER IT'S- A PASTE UP. A
FULL NINE DIGITS WHAT. ID JUST.
AND BY. BY BY THEIR
INTERPRETATION OF FEDERAL LAW
IT'S A- I HAVE ONE OF THOSE
THINGS NOW THINGS HAVE CHANGED
OVER AND OVER A LIFE. EMPIRE
MORE THINGS WE SHOULD. MAYBE
FOR OTHER DAY DISCUSSION BUT
YOU KNOW FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
FULL SOCIAL ON BASED ABROAD.
CAN BE USED IN LIEU OF THE
SECURE I THINK THERE'S AVENUES
THAT PEOPLE CAN ALTERNATE IS
THAT ARE. REALLY YEAH COMMON
THAT PEOPLE CAN USE IF THE P.
BEGINNING OF THAT. THAT'S GOOD
TO HEAR BECAUSE YOU RAISE
ANOTHER ISSUE AND THAT IS THE
WORLD TURNED ABOUT. PERSONAL
DATA SECURITY THIS IS THE
NUMBER IS THE NUMBER ONE THING
THAT WE- COLLECTIVELY BELIEVE
WE SHOULDN'T BE SHARE WITH
ANYBODY RIGHT SO NOW WE HAVE. A
STATE ASK FOR THAT INFORMATION.
TO DOING THAT. THAT'S GOING TO
BE TOUGH TO OVERCOME. IS SO IS
THE DMV KEEPING TRACK OF THE
NUMBER OF END OF IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO REACH DOES IT BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE PROPER. A
SET OF. MISSION PAPERS ANY VERY.
WE ARE. SYRIAN WHERE ARE I DO
NOT KEEPING TRACK OF MULTIPLE
VISITS FULL ISSUES THANK YOU.
WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE A LOT.
THIS CALL IS NOT MUCH LAST. YOU
A CALL THEN YOU'RE CALLING
AGAIN I DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY BY AND LARGE WE
SAMPLE. PEOPLE COME IN THERE
SOME DATA SOME SIX THE SYSTEM
THAT'LL HELP US UNDERSTAND
THAT. AND WE JUST WANT TO WE
WANT TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
VISITS BECAUSE I NUMBER OF IT
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IF BUDGET.
TWENTY MINUTES WOULD TAKE
TWENTY MINUTES FIRST TIME A-
SECOND TIME. SO WE- TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THAT IN TERMS OF. THE
FOR THE FIRST STOP INTO THE
DMV. CHECKING YOUR DOCTOR THE
TRIAGE DESK. YOU HAVE.
TRANSACTION OUR MESSAGING IS A
VERY FOCUS ON GETTING THAT
INFORMATION IN YOUR HANDS I
WOULD HAVE TO BRING IN WORLD.
ROLL OUT SOME ANOTHER THIS CAN
HELP US NOW. MANY OF THOSE
THINGS. TAKE IT JOE BEGIN TO
HELP THE. IT HAS FOR THOSE.
THIS I USED TO NOT A PROBLEM
THEM EXTENSIVELY THEY HAVE A
REALLY GOOD MOVIE. PHOTO IF
YOU'RE A VOTER PASSPORT.
KEIICHI WITHOUT SO WITH ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS GO SKATE ON THE
CHECK IN COUNTER REASON
TECHNOLOGY FOR ROLE IN A
TECHNOLOGY AS WE SPEAK THAT
HAVE THE SAME CAPABILITIES TO
POP. BUT ONE OF THE SKIN AND
WHAT THE CREDENTIAL DOCUMENT
YOU WANT TO SCAN IN. THE REST.
TWENTY ONE A SCANT. IT IS A TO
BE BEFORE YOU. MORE KITCHEN
KITCHEN TABLE WHERE YOU DO YOUR
WORK YOU'LL KNOW WHAT DO YOU
HAVE. UP YOU KNOW SEVERAL. WE
LIKE TO THINK WE'RE GONNA TAKE
MINISTRY LET ALONE NUMBER TO BE
MORE. THIS IS. TEN MILLION
PEOPLE COMING IN OVER THE NEXT.
TEN WE DON'T HAVE A DRIVE
THROUGH THE BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
IT IS EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE AND
THINGS WERE TAKING BECAUSE WE
THINK WE VALUE OUR CUSTOMERS
AND WE VALUE THE STATE'S I'M AS
A TAXPAYER I VALUE THE MONEY
INVESTED IN THIS I MEAN I WANT
TO COLLECT ALL THE RIGHT THINGS
AND THAT'S IT IS TO THE
PORTFOLIO THE WERE WORKING. AS
WE SPEAK. SO I'M GOING TO. MY
CALL TO FIVE. YES BEFORE THAT
HAPPENS ALL JUST ASK ONE- AND
THAT IS- OF CALIFORNIA- AS A
MULTITUDE OF LANGUAGES. CAN I
AND IS THE. A REACH EFFORT WHAT
IS THE OUTREACH EFFORTS OF
THOSE WHO ARE NOT IN ENGLISH.
PROBABLY THE- AND SO ON. I
DON'T HAVE I DO OF THE SUMMER
IN THIS PAPERWORK BUT TEN IF
YOU WILL IS THAT WERE TARGETING
THAT WE BELIEVE ARE ARE HIGH
VOLUME WE HAVE A RESIDENTS IN
SAID MAYBE THEY'LL REALLY PUT
UP IN A MESSAGE AND RAN FOR
EXAMPLE. IN ADDITION TO SPANISH
THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINGS.
LANGUAGE IS WE KNOW THAT AND
MANY OF THESE CAN. A LANGUAGE
SPOKEN SO WE ARE. SINCE THAT WE.
DOES THAT THAT I THINK RUN
UNIVISION TONIGHT IN THE BAY
AREA- PEOPLE ARE DOING IN
SPANISH I'M IN A CALL TO FOR
PEOPLE AT RELATED QUESTIONS
WOULD ON THE- SIMILAR. AS NO
AND SO ON SO. EVERY AVAILABLE
TO ANYBODY THAT WILL HAVE US
YOU WERE. IN THE IN LOCAL
LANGUAGE SPANISH HAS BEEN
EASIER FOR US BUT WE'RE ALSO
GONNA REACH OUT VIA SOCIAL
MEDIA NOW THEY'RE- INVOLVED.
THANK YOU. ROOM FOR HOLDING.
UPDATING US ON YOUR REAL ID
LIMÓN XIN APPERT. OUT I ADMIT
IS A REAL LIFE HI TO ALL. AND I
HAVE A HEARING- BUT I PLAN TO
GO TO. THE. I ATTENDED THE-
AND- AND SO I PLAN I DON'T NEED
AN APPOINTMENT SO I CAN JUST
POP IT MAKES ME VERY HAPPY. AND
SO I'M EXCITED TO TRY THAT OUT.
CENTER. MY QUESTION IS I
NOTICED RECENTLY WHEN I. FLIGHT
THAT THE T. WHEN. MY I. D.
HOUSE. HE DID YOU KNOW THAT YOU
NEED ONE BY OCTOBER FOR. A
LIGHT THAT I'VE TAKEN. I'M AND
I THOUGHT ALL THAT THIS IS
GREAT WITH MINE PEOPLE I AND
I'M NOT. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
TAKE INITIATIVE ABOUT THAT MADE
ME THINK WHERE ELSE CAN WE DO
THAT MAYBE AT THING AT THE
STATE EIGHT C. OR SOME WE'RE
SORRY. PRESENT TEEN RIGHT. FOR
ANOTHER SERVICE AT. THE REAL ID
BY OCTOBER FIRST. DO YOU HAVE.
HOW OR HOW CAN WE LOOK INTO. SO
I THINK THAT THE SENATE FOREVER
THIS RIVAS I COULD BE ABSOLUTE
SHOULD DO THAT I THINK WHAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON PRIMARILY TO.
FOCUS MORE ON THE TRUMP BASE.
YOU KNOW. WHAT THE TIAS IS
DOING T. R. A MATERIAL IN
VARIOUS AIRPORTS MANY OF A
RECEPTIVE TO DIGITAL. ALSO HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON YOUR PART
COUNCIL MEMBER WITH HIM.
THEY'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
ACTIVITY OR TRY KERR'S AND DO
MORE AND WITH US AS YOU HEAR
FOR. YOU NEXT. IN THAT AREA
INCLUDING. YOU'LL GET A REAL ID
OR MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
ADDITIONAL BUT I LIKE YOUR IDEA
IN TERMS OF OTHER SERVICES WE
HAVE A SEAT AS FAR AS I RECALL
EMILY BRANCHED OUT TO THE OTHER
STATES SERVICES THAT RECALL OUR
ID TO COMPLETE THE TRANSACTION.
IT SEEMS LIKE A GOOD IDEA. WILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I WAS
INTERESTED IN THE TOP IN IN IN
TURN TO GO HEADING UP TO THE
DMV SOMETHING ALREADY THE
REGULAR TO UNDERSTAND OF A DROP
IN WINDOWS SOMEBODY COMES IN.
ORDER THERE. HE ASKS US IN THE
MEMORY AS HE HAVE APPOINTMENTS
NOT APPOINTMENTS TO THE THEY'VE
NOT ONE WOULD BE WOULD HAVE
BEEN. AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
TO THESE. MORE SPACE FOR THOSE
TRANSACTIONS JOKER OUR CONTRACT
AT A NUDGE PEOPLE TO THOSE HERE
WE ARE WITH A POINT TO THE
TRUCK AT YOUR QUESTION IS YES
WE ACTUALLY DO THAT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF NOT OF. TRANSACTIONS
AND THOSE WAIT TIMES I'M DOWN
TO. HELLO THEY WERE TO HEAR AGO
OUR MEALS. HILL A SHORT YOU
MAKE THE WEIGHT ON ME. SALAS
TIMES AND. OFFICE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T STAND AROUND WITH NO
CUSTOMERS AWAY NOT I MEAN
THAT'S MADE ME SOUND LIKE AN
IDEAL STATE BUT PROBABLY WANT
TO BE SOMEWHERE SOMEONE OF A
DIFFERENT FROM THERE ACT YOUR
QUESTION WE WANNA MAKE. PEOPLE
ARE. HAVE YOU HAVE. THE NOTION
THAT THE ONLY WAY YOU GET
SERVICE YOU MAKE AN APPOINTMENT
AN APPOINTMENT STARTS THE UNION
COMMAND UNDER SAY THE WAIT
TIMES ARE AS LOW AS A PREVENT
YOU SHOULD DROP AND NOW WE HAVE
NOW TEXT MESSAGE DEAN AT THIS
TIME FOR A COMPANY CALLED THE
MEDICS WE COULD TELL YOU. LIKE
RESTAURANTS HEY YOU'VE REACHED
GREAT HERE THIRD MINE START
HEADING BACK TO THE. HEY HERE
FIRST YOU SHOULD BE A- PHYSICAL
BUILDING. SO I HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO. THEY
COULDN'T WAIT START. CONCERT
WHEREVER WHEREVER THEY GO. HE'S
IN THE OTHER TO THE- I'VE DONE
A TIME. POSSIBILITIES. HANSEN
DROPPING EXPERIENCE OF PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE TO BE STOPPED WHEN
THEY MIGHT NEED TO GO UNDER TWO
AND WE HAVE. THE TO NOTIFY THEM
WHEN THEIR TIME AT THE WHEN
IT'S READY. THANK YOU. IN MY
COMMUNITY YOU IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY- HAVE EXPRESSED GREAT
CONCERN. NEW BILL I. D. FIND
THE FOUNDER THE PATH FOR
IMMIGRANT. OF COMPLICATED STEP.
GET PROCESS. WHAT
IDENTIFICATION. GOING TO BE
WILL CONTINUE ONE WITH REGULAR
DRIVER'S LICENSE CORRECT. SO
THE DAD IS A SERIOUS CONCERN IN
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY THAT
HAVE. CATION THAT WILL SHOW
ANYBODY THE- DOCUMENTED.
SOMEBODY WHO HAS STATION. DIEM
TO HELP LEGISLATURE DEAL WITH
THIS A SIMILAR- YES THE
CALIFORNIA IS AN OPTIONAL STATE
OF THE LOS UP SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN OPT IN TO A REAL ID OR OPT
OUT AND HAVE A CAR THAT'S NOT
FEDERALLY COMPLIANT. SO I THINK.
THE LAWMAKING BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT IS OUR CITED HOW
THAT'S GOING TO WORK. JOB
EXECUTE ON THOSE SO SOMEBODY
DOESN'T MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
THEY HAVE A PATH HE WHICH IS. I
THINK. WHAT YOU'RE. AND FOR
MANY WHO DECIDED THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO GET A REAL LADY
IN THAT MIGHT BE PART OF. THE
NOT COMPLY WHICH THEY CAN DO
THAT. YEAH I'VE GOT A FULL
ENTRY CARDS I COULD EASILY GET
OF NONCOMPLIANCE HE'S A
COLLECTOR TOGETHER. AND I WOULD
BE PER COMPLY. ALL OF LOS I
CAN'T TELL. YOU CAN HOW THEY-
BUT HE A DOCTOR. YOU KNOW RIGHT
AROUND FIFTY IN ORDER TO DRIVE
THAT NORTHBOUND REASONS THAT
WILL. ABOUT WITH. COMMERCE IN
TONE AS WITH. PARKS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE VERY AT THE SAME TIME.
THE OTHER GROUP ISN'T JUST
PEOPLE TALKING STERN. AND. THAT
WE THAT'S WHAT THEY ASK FOR
THAT SO WE GET. GOOD EIGHT IN
THE DOCUMENTS. PREPARATION FOR
THERE WERE. INFORMATION RELATED
TO. THAT WAS DONE BY THE RIVER
VIEW OF DIEM. THEY DON'T IT'S
AN EVALUATIONS CLEARLY BEFORE
YOUR TIME- BUT- AS YOU KNOW YOU.
TING INTO A DEPARTMENT THAT
HOUSE RECEIVED. SYSTEM. IT CAN
MANY REGARD TO WELD THIS IS A
IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THAT THEIR
CHANGES BEING MADE. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE TO COME IT. IS A
SERVICES. IN OUR. THE TRAIN.
AND THEIR THEIR AND WE HAVE
SOME. IT'S ALL MUSIC- DOWN TO
TALK ABOUT CRITICISMS BECAUSE
THE CRITICISMS DIRECTED ONE OR
TWO WERE JUST A FEW.
UNFORTUNATELY GOT TIRED TO PART
OF THE BECAME A CULTURE OF THE-
SO THAT I SEE THAT AS A
CHALLENGE AND I KNOW THERE HAVE
BEEN. GREAT EFFORTS MADE TO.
MAKE THINGS BETTER AND
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT. VERY
SPECIFICALLY ON THE TRAINING OF
THE STAFF. ON THE CHANGE OF THE
CULTURE OF THE DMV. WHAT WHAT
HAS BEEN WHAT'S YOUR VISION AND
HOW IS IT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
GET THERE. COUPLE QUESTION SO.
TO LET'S SAY THE FRONT. I THINK
WE SAW. THE KIDS ARE BEFORE IT
ARRIVES THIS OPERATIONS
EXCELLENCE. THE STAMP DOWN THE
DMV FRONTLINE AND PLEASE. WITH
THAT WAS ON THE DAY ARE AT THE
END OF THE DAY AND HE WAS FULLY
ALIGNED WITH THE MISSION WHAT
WAS READ. THEM. HOW TO. PERFORM
THEIR- BEST I SAW. THE RESULTS.
FOR IN TERMS OF JUST LOOKING
DISTRICTS. IDENTITY MORE LIGHT
IN THE OPERATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS POST. NIXON STAY
WAS SENT TO THAN PRE WHAT I CAN
TO COME YEAH AT THE TEN OR 15%
MOVE ON A FAIRLY LARGE NUMBERS
IS IMPRESSED EITHER
TRANSACTION. I THINK THE TEAM I
THINK BETTER UNDERSTOOD BETTER
THAN NO TRAINING TO BE GETTING
YEAH THE WIND THE MORNING AFTER
OUR. I HAPPEN IN BROAD I THINK
THAT THE CHALLENGE HAS TO DO
THAT HE- ORGANIZATIONAL YOU
KNOW IN IT AND HOW THE F.
ORGANIZE EDIT. AND I WAS IN IN
THE IN THE OC OUT AS WELL I
READ THAT DURING MY PROCESS I
WAS WHEN THE PUBLIC DOCUMENTS
LIKE IT LEARN ABOUT THE V. IN
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THERE'S
BEEN SIX CHARGES UP. TO YOU TO
CHANGE HOW WE MAKE. AND I
GIPSON SAMPLE AWHILE AGO. FIELD
OPERATIONS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
HOWARD HUGHES THE CYCLE.
INTERESTING SACRAMENTO THINK
ABOUT THINGS SHOULD BE IN HE'LL
BUT IF THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY IN
THE FIELD THEY REALLY DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS BEING ASKED OF THE
EMPLOYEE AND HOW THAT. I THINK.
IN THOSE DECISIONS RIGHT THIS
OP WITH THE CLUB CREST. THOSE
DECISION RIGHT DOING THE WORK.
CONSULT WITH OTHER FOLLOWING
THE LAW. WITH THAT MOVEMENT WE
ARE ABLE TO SEE SUBSTANTIAL
MOVE IN IN THE IN THE TIME IT
TAKES TO PROCESS THE
TRANSACTION BECAUSE OPERATIONS
TEAM HAD A IF THE WELL YOU KNOW
THAT. THEY WERE IN THAT. THEY
ACTUALLY KNEW WHAT DO YOU DO IT.
REALLY DID WHAT THE MODEL
SENSITIVE. IT IS LIKE THAT THE
MOVE. KIND OF A VERY RISK
AVERSE CULTURE SACRAMENTO
STREET CULTURE TOO. BY MAKING
DECISIONS WE NEED AIRPORT AND I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE THERE
ARE A LOT DIRECTION WE'RE
TRYING TO GO BUT IF YOU IN
THAT. IS A LOOK ON TUESDAY
BETWEEN THESE TWO. YOU CAN
PRETTY MUCH YOU NEED. DROUGHT
WHAT'S GOING TO WORK IN. ACROSS
THE STATE. VERY GOOD IN A SHORT
BY CHANCE HE TAKING SOME OF THE
SHACKLES OFF OFF THE FIELD AND
WE HAVE TO DO THIS WAS NOT JUST
OKAY WAY I SO WANTED DOWN THE
CHAIN THING IS FINE. BUT NOW
HE'S SERVING OKAY INTO THE
CULTURE TO THAT. ONE RESPOND
WITH TRENDY INTEREST IN WHY
THEIR TRUCK WHEN I WAS TRYING
TO DO. SO THINK ABOUT TEST THE
HYPOTHESIS RUNNING EXPERIMENTS.
YOU KNOW SIXTY THAT THE START
AND STOP AN EVALUATION SO WE.
WE LEARNED WHAT WE EXPECT
TESTING SYSTEM. POSITIVE
NEGATIVE OKAY RIGHT NOW WHAT'S
THE NEXT BERMAN EXPERIMENT WE
GET SIDE. THANKS THIS IS THE.
FOR YEARS AND THAT'S KEEP DOING
WHAT HE SAID THEY WERE ACTING
STE WHICH IS HOW WE GOT THIS
TWENTY MINUTE TESTING TIME FOR
REAL. ANOTHER GOOD IDEA. AFTER
WE TOO MUCH OF A GOOD THING SO
WE NEED TO REALLY KIND OF
UNWIND AND THAT'S REALLY I WANT
MY TEAM TO BE ABLE TO THINK ON
THEIR OWN TO PRESENT THEIR
ARGUMENTS. HOW WE SHOULD DO
WHATEVER ENTITIES. ITS YEAH
THEY- YOUR. HE IS REALLY GOOD
CALLS ON THIS BUT. THE CULTURE
IS PULLING IT ACTION NO MATTER
MY NEW LEADERSHIP AND OTHER
CULTURES GOING TO KILL US WE'VE
GOT TO GET. THE EXISTING WORK
OUT WHERE WE GO THROUGH
DECISION MAKING DECISION RIGHTS
OWNERSHIP ACCOUNTABILITY THE
ROLE OF TECHNOLOGY THE BE AND
HOW WE USED. IN A MODERN ENTER.
KEEP IN MIND THAT OUT LEAVE THE
OTHER NIGHT AND WE. THE TOP
FROM THE TOP WE HAVE ALL THE-
IN FRONT OF US BUT FOR WHATEVER
REASON WE WALK INTO. THE WE-
BUT CAN NUMBER THINGS WERE
TRYING TO DO TO MAKE PEOPLE
FEEL. AWARE OF THE REAL WORLD
WORKS AND ONE PART OF A
STRAIGHT EDGE WITHOUT STATUTES
BUT VISIT CULTURE RATE UNTIL
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
EXPECTED OF THEM IN MARIN SAGE
THE DMV AND WHAT WHAT'S
EXPECTED OF THE STATE WHAT'S
EXPECTED MOTION FOR THE FROM
FROM THE CUSTOMERS. HE TO THAT
PERSON SITTING ACROSS FROM THEM
AT THE COUNTER IS THEIR
NEIGHBOR OR FRIEND THEIR
RELATIVE. AND HAS AN ECONOMIC
IMPACT THAT TWENTY MINUTES OF
THEM SITTING THERE IS TWENTY
MINUTES ARE NOT SPENT AND
TAKING CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN
THEY'RE NOT TAKING CARE OF A
FAMILY MEMBER NOT WORKING. AND
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND PROGRESS IN THE
STATE AND. WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE IS AWARE THAT'S
WE MAKE THE DECISION. THE ONE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE
OFTENTIMES IT COMES TOP. I
THINK THAT- I APPRECIATE THAT
WE HAVE- WERE WE- HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT FALL TEN. IT'S
GOING TO OPEN UP. THE DMV
OFFICE OF THE BEEN CLOSED APRIL
EIGHT SEIU IS HOW. I THINK THAT
BEING HOURS. THE. KUDOS TOUR
FOR PUTTING SO MUCH FROM
SACRAMENTO. AND. HELPING THEM
TO GET. EXTREMELY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO JUST
THAT SO THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MY
SQUARE. ON THE STAFF. VERY
SPECIFICALLY DMV WAS GIVEN THE
AUTHORITY TO HIRE AND TRAIN
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHT. ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS AS OF JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I'VE HAD
THIRTY SIX OFFERS HAVE BEEN
MADE THREE FORTY FIVE STAFF HAD
ORDERED RECEIVING TRAINING AND
WORKING. CLOSER TO THE SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WHEREABOUTS ARE WE
AND IT'S HOLDING UP. GETTING
RELEASED RIGHT SO. MOST KERN
NUMBERS I HAVE AN HOUR FROM
COMBINED. THE COMBINED A
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THAT
GRANTED BOTH SHE PIECED
TOGETHER AND MADE OFFERS ON
SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
HAVE STARTED. THAT'S ABOUT
NINETY FOUR PER. WE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS AND I KNOW
THE NUMBERS BROKEN DOWN IN IN
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT COLLECTIVELY
FOR BOTH PC P. I THINK. WE'RE
NOT GONNA REST. WE'RE DONE WERE
MADE ATTENTION WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A RETENTION ISSUE.
THE CONTENT POSITION. RIGHT WE
ALL THE WAY UP IS TO MANAGE
APPS THE FACT THIS WEEK ONE
PART OF THAT A BIG PART THIS IS
OUR WORKFORCE WONDERFUL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER. YOU'RE
WELCOME. THE JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE HUMAN RESOURCES ASPECT OF
FOR A OF THE DMV. CAN YOU TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE OTHER
ONES AS YOU FACE THE. HE IN IN
FIRST SURE AND WHAT THE PLAN IS
GOING. A NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES I
THINK YOU'RE WELL AWARE WE
HAVE. IT IS SYSTEMS THE GREAT
NEWS ABOUT THE DATA SYSTEMS
THEY WERE EXTREMELY WELL
ARCHITECTED BACK IN THE SIXTIES
AND SEVENTIES SO COULD THOSE.
AT TEAM. GREAT JOB. WE NEVER
INTENDED THAT THEY WOULD BE
RUNNING IN IN THE YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN OR TWENTY TWENTY SO
WE'LL TRY TO MAKE PEACE I DO
COME WITH A TECH BACKGROUND I'M
NOT. PROBABLY VERY LITTLE BUT I
KNOW ABOUT ENOUGH RIGHT. WHEN
WE LOOK AT THIS COUPLE HUNDRED
ONE IS AT THE DAY OF COURSE
THE- ON IT WAS. SURE WHOSE NAME
WAS ABOUT THE BRAND BUT THE NET.
ABLE INFRASTRUCTURE SO I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE- COMCAST.
SAID WE'VE WE'VE AWARDED THE
THAT IT IS A HIGH SPEED
RELIABLE NETWORK THERE WOULD BE
NO DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER
BUSINESS YOU WOULD RUN AND
TODAY WE HAVE SPEEDS AND FEEDS
IT'S CALLED IN THE STREET
BETTER OUT OF ALL WITH
BUSINESSES OF OUR SIZE AND
SCALE NUMBER TRANSACTIONS THAT
WE DO. SO ONE THING IS LAYING
DOWN THAT FOUNDATION SO WE. BOB
IS A COMMUNITY BANK. WE CAN
OPERATE SERVERS WE- THINGS
MISSING PRETTY PERSPECTIVE. HEY
WE CAN EVEN DO REMOTE TRAINING
EIGHT I KID YOU NOT. WHEN WE
WHAT WE'RE DOING SOME ASPECTS
OF TRADE WE MAIL. A DVD IF
YOU'RE NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE BAND WITH SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY DOWNLOAD. IN REAL
TIME. THERE'S SEVEN MEG. MUCH
WE CAN'T THAT'S FOUND IT
FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENT TO
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO. NOW THE
TRICKY PART IS SOME OF THESE
THE LEGACY SYSTEMS THAT ARE
RUNNING REGISTRATION AND
LICENSING. SO OUR- FIRST ORDER
OF BUSINESS THAT WE'VE- FOR
THOSE OF YOU THE BEEN IN AN
INDUSTRY WE'VE- CAN. YOU CALL
IF YOU'VE HEARD OF A HOLIDAY.
SURE THE STATE AS A FREED ON
CHANGES DURING A LOT THERE. THE
HOLIDAYS WHEN PEOPLE ARE GONNA
BE AVAILABLE SO WE'VE PUT A
FREEZE ON. I WAS KIND OF
FRAGILE APPLICATIONS AND I. IN
THIS TO TWO OTHER FOLKS INSTEAD
OF MY MOM IS AN EIGHT YEARS
OLD. SHE ANIMAL COLLECTIVE
SURGERY. AND WE DON'T MAKE A
DEAL CHOICES THINGS PERHAPS I
MIGHT DONE IN A MORE MODERN WAY
OUT OF THE SYSTEM SO LET'S NOT
GO UNDER THE KNIFE LET'S NOT.
AND RUN THAT RISK. IS
DISCRETIONARY. MINIMIZE.
SYSTEMS ARE. PRODIGY SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO GET FOR AND SO
WE'VE BEEN WITH NUMBER OF
SUPPLIERS HELP US WITH
TECHNOLOGY SO WE CAN ADMIT
LEGACY SYSTEMS WITH MODERN
TECHNOLOGIES HELP US ARE.
TRANSITIONAL STRAP SAID
DIFFERENTLY IS THAT WERE. NEW.
CARMIE SOME BRIEF KNOWLEDGE HE
AND THAT GIVES US THE TIME TO
THINK AHEAD NOW AND OKAY WE
WANT TO GO FROM THE OLD TO THE
NEW WHAT DO WE BRING WITH US
YOU KNOW WHICH WE RECORDED WHAT
WE THINK THE WORLD THE LAST
THIRTY. YEARS AND HOW YOU
MIGHT. LOOK AT. IN THE PAST
BECAUSE OF ARCHITECTURE. WHICH
IT MAY BE VERY HARD TO CLEAN
NAY. AND WE CAN. THAT WE
COULDN'T TO BACK IN THE SIX
SEVENTY SO I THINK WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A PLAN WHERE AT THE IN THE
VERY AND SEE OF THIS YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN ON. FOR A HUNDRED
DAYS NOW. WE'RE DONE. APPOINTED
MYSELF THANK YOU FOR CALLING.
IF THERE'S BUT WE ARE AWARE OF
THOSE IS. OKAY COMPRESS
FOUNDATION KICKED OFF WITH A- I
THINK THAT WOULD. WE HAVE A LOT
MORE WORK TO BELIEVE ANYTHING A-
WE WON'T. STOP WE'RE TRYING TO
BE SURE WE- KNOW MORE HARM AT
THE SAME TIME. WE CAN ACTUALLY.
THANK WELL I GO BUT FIRST IS A
MESS NO FOR ANY CEO ANY THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS CRITICS. I'LL
CALL AND THOROUGH IN YOUR
APPROACH TO THAT TIME AND I'M
SURE THAT'LL PAY OFF IN THE
FUTURE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THEN I WILL JUST CLICK. I ON
BEHALF OF MY SON IS CONTINUING
CARE AT HAVING FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO RECEIVED AN AUTOMATIC FAIL
AND IS HAVING TESTS. AT THE I
THINK. TO REPRESS THE- WRONG
YEARS NOTED. KERRY'S THAT EVERY
THAT. YOU'RE COMING ALL THE WAY
DOWN FROM UP SACRAMENTO AND
LOOK FORWARD TO. OUR FUTURE
HERPES AND UP IT'S AS WE MOVE.
AGAIN IS COMPRISED OF ONE
INDIVIDUAL. THE COST AS WELL
NOW. CORD. WE HAVE A CARE TELL.
FROM VISIT CALIFORNIA. WHO IS
GOING TO US PICKED US UP AND
THE- CONCERN ABOUT THE ACT. OF
THE. THIS ISSUE MIGHT HAVE ON
TOURISM. WELCOME. AND WITH THAT
YEAH. I CANNOT BELIEVE YOU TWO
SHARING THIS INFORMATION IN A
PUBLIC THAT IS BEING TELEVISED.
THE ROOM. THEY HEARD MISTER.
FIND OUT FROM BETWEEN THE TWO
OF US LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS UP THERE AND NOW I
THINK WE'RE MEANT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE ANYWAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR THE TIME TO THIS IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AS YOU
HAVE- ILLUSTRATED AND FOR US. I
IN THE TRASH IN THE STREETS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ECONOMICALLY AS WE
ALL. I THINK IT IS A DONE A
GREAT JOB OBVIOUSLY LET OUT THE
SHE- LIVING WITH THAT. TIME BUT
AS YOU MENTIONED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. IT JUST IN PERSON DAY
SEVENTY EIGHT ON PEOPLE COULD
BE TURNED AWAY. FIVE FORTY NINE
FIVE THOUSAND EIGHT WEEK COSTS
IN THE TROUT ECONOMY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. JUST ONE DARE
TO EAT IN DOLLARS WE. I THINK
OF YOU MENTION THAT ACTUALLY
16% OF AMERICANS BELIEVE THEY.
I BELIEVE THEY ARE A REAL COME
IN. EIGHTY TWO THEY'RE NOT SURE
THEY ARE ARE IN FACT NOT AT
THAT POINT. THAT REALLY FOR
CALIFORNIA. ONE TROUBLED S. U.
S. ARE WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
PERCENT SHARE OF DOMESTIC
VISITATION I AND THAT MEANS WE
ARE A S. THAT WE SEE LOSE ABOUT
EIGHT MILLION A DAY- DON'T
CONTINUE TO REACH OUT TO GET. A
REAL ID. IN THE FIRST MONTH
ALONE I A- BY. WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY HUGE AS YOU KNOW- I
WILL SPENDING POWERS LÀ AND MY
SERVER. PLEASE THROUGH SALES
TAX RIGHT THE KNOCKING. SO
WE'RE GONNA JUST SEE A REAL
CRASH IN THE STRAIN EVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REVENUE- IF WE DON'T
WORK TOGETHER TO GET THIS OUT
SO WE FEEL COMPELLED TO BE
SUPPORT OF YOUR EFFORTS AS WELL
AS THE DMV- THE DMV OBVIOUSLY
IS WORKING VERY HARD AT GETTING
THE WORD OUT- BUT THE END OF
THE DAY THERE WANT ORGANIZATION
AND ONE CHANNEL. SO WERE
THRILLED TO BE HERE TO BE SOME
OF. SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE DOING STAND FORMA. IT IS
WORKING AMBER ALERT THE U. S.
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION CREATE A
REAL LIFE BE. UNLAWFUL. OF THAT
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION.
BOARD LONG STEVE KERNS AND IT'S
A TOURIST. IT IT REVOLVES
AROUND THE CASSETTE TAG REAL ID
READY. HE IS IN THE TRAVEL
INDUSTRY COME TOGETHER ON NASH
ONLY UNDER CONSISTENCY
MESSAGING. ENDS REAL ID READY
THE REAL IMPACTS FOR US SAID
CANONICALLY IS IF THE REST OF
THE NATION ISN'T REAL ID READY
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WERE
WORK WITH OUR NAP TRAVEL
INDUSTRY. PARTNERS. SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE FIRST AND
FOREMOST. I ALLY IN ARKANSAS
CHANNELS WE HAVE THIRTY THREE
MILLION FOLLOWERS ON OUR OWN
CHANNEL NETWORK IT IS A
CALIFORNIA TO COMMUNICATE REAL
ID. WE HAVE A TRAVEL TIPS THAT
IS VERY POPULAR THE MOST
POPULAR PART OF OUR OVERALL WEB
TAKE WE SEE ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION UNIQUE TO YEAR AS PART
OF OUR WEB TRAFFIC. AND
TOGETHER OF THE REAL HE READY
INFORMATION RIGHT ON THAT PAGE
AS I SAID IT'S THE MOST POPULAR.
WE HAVE A LARGER PUSH PLANNED
AS WE TURN THE CORNER INTO THE
NEW YEAR. FOR REAL ID AND ASKS
ARE STARTING FIRST FOREMOST
WITH OUR CALIPHS DETERS GUIDE
WILL PRINT OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ANNUALLY BUT WE SEE
MANY MANY MORE. WE HAVE A OUT
AND Q. R. CODE. CANNOT INTO
THAT OUR GUIDE I IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA NOW
BLOG THAT HAS A- FIFTY THOUSAND
USERS AND IS GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY BY THE DAY-
ACTUALLY AND NEWSLETTER
SUBSCRIBERS REACHING ALMOST
THREE MORE. WILL BE PUSHING
THAT OUT. ON CHANNELS AS WELL
AS OUR- MEDIA CHANNELS AS
SUDDENLY IT I AM OPPORTUNITIES
WE HAVE A NETWORK OF TWENTY ONE.
NURSE THESE. TWO MILLION PEOPLE.
SO THROUGH WELCOME CENTERS- AS
WELL WITH OUR CUSTOM TING PART.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE PUBLISHING
HOUSE IS IN THE WORLD WOULD
PASS THEM FOR CONSIDERATION
WOMEN EXPECT ALL OVER THERE ARE
WHOLLY OWNED SUBSIDIARY LIKE
MINE IN A MAGAZINE AND BETTER.
THAT WE HAVE AND THE JUST CO
OPTING FROM ON GLOBAL READY
FRANKLY IS ALREADY THERE IS
OPPORTUNITIES ON GROUP
FUNCTIONS OR LARGE GROUPS OF
PEOPLE ON IT WE HAVE A GLOBAL
OUTLOOK. SEE. BECAUSE THE
FAMILY LEADERS THE COME. AND
PERHAPS. STRAIN OUR GROUP IS
THAT I THOUGHT WAS A GREAT IDEA
YOU HAD AROUND THEIR AGENCIES.
IF WE CAN KIND OF THE SCRAPE
THAT MODEL AND DO IT OR-
CALIFORNIA. THE WE ALL KIND OF
EXCITED WITH I THINK THAT WOULD
BE BETTER OFF WITH ME THAT'S
WHAT I HAVE AND WE'RE JUST HERE
TO. PARTNER CONTINUING TO GET
THAT. OUT REACH OUT IT IS A
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR THE U.
S. TRAVEL ASSOCIATION NOW
BECAUSE OF THE NATIONAL ACTS
BUT WE IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT THE
MOST BECAUSE WERE THE LARGEST.
A LITTLE BIT MORE. ABOUT OUR
FAILURE OF OTHER STATES TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE REAR
AFFECT CALIFORNIA YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SO AS I SAID WE'RE
THE LARGEST TRAVEL DESTINATION
LAUGHS. ABOUT CENTER CARE OF
OVERALL MARKETS. IF OUR ID
COMPLY SIDE OF CALIFORNIAN THEY
GO TO GET A- AND TURNED AWAY.
DEVASTATING. THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE WATCH ALL AND WE HAVE AN
WHY ARE TRAVEL INDUSTRY PART IS
UP AND CAL. I'VE MOST
AGGRESSIVELY. AS AN EXAM NO WE
WERE NOT REALLY FOCUS ON IN
STATE PER SE BUT THOSE STATE OF
VISITORS THAT ACTUALLY SPEND
MORE MONEY AND STATE. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY AND FOR
BRING TIONAL BACK. ON THE REAL
IDEA LIMÓN ACTION AND HOW IT
AFFECTS. DOING THREE IMPLEMENT
TEN AND IS THERE ONE FIRST
YOU'RE MORE WITH. THE MAJORITY.
THAT MAYBE WE COULD FOCUS ON. I
WOULD HAVE TO ANSWER THAT. I
THINK EVEN THE TRAVEL INDUSTRY
JOHNSTON LAST THREE MONTHS HAS
REALLY REYES THIS. THERE WERE
OUR OWN TRAVEL DISTRICT. SO
HERE THIS HEARING IS. ACTUALLY
HAVE SO SECTION BOARD NOTHING
RIGHT NOW. IN WASHINGTON BUT WE
FELT WAS MORE IMPORTANT. PART
OF THIS DISCUSSION SO THAT.
AROUND BEST PRACTICE. IS TAKING
PLACE TOMORROW- FRIDAY TO SPEAK
MORE WILL BE ABLE TO. TOO MANY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WISH TROUT-
HAS ALSO RELEASED A SERIES OF
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS. ARE THE
FIRST ONE IS MODERNIZE REAL
ID'S UT. WORKING WITH ANY OF
OUR NATIONAL UNDER THE- PLEASE.
ON NINE AND YES THERE ARE-
SEVERAL- TENANTS OF THAT AROUND
AND EDUCATING AND BRINGING
ABOUT. THE RESPONSIBILITY
LEVELS WITH TSA. PLANS EXCEPT
I'M JUST USE SOMEONE NUMBER
THERE I'VE ONLY BEEN STOPPED
QUESTION ONE TIME I AM STILL
WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
ENTERS. AS WELL AS WITH THE
AIRLINES WHERE YOU'RE BEING A
BOOKING WINDOW IS MOVING PAST
OCTOBER FIRST AND YET. NO IT
THREE TWO PEOPLE THAT ARE
BOOKING PAST OCTOBER FIRST
EXCEPT FOR A AMERICAN AIRLINES
BUT AT LEAST THREE LIKE TO CARE
ABOUT CARE AT THIS POINT. NOT
REGULAR AID VISINE OR PUTTING
NOT FORWARD AROUND THEIR WEB.
CHECK AT THE AT. EIGHT SO THAT
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE FOR US. YOU
KNOW THE THING THAT JUST CAME
TO MIND I'M IS THAT PERHAPS THE
DMV NEEDS TO HAVE A WINDOW AT
THE AIRPORT. BUT FOR THOSE WHO
ARE THE. FIRST THEY CAN CALL
THEIR AND GET THE TEMPORARY ID.
I. TSA PRECHECK SOME OF.
METHODS OF THE SHOW COMPLIANCE
OR TO COMPLIANCE- SO YOUR IDEAS.
IT MEANT THAT WAS NOTED I THINK
IS THE MOST. RUNNING A LARGE
RESERVE GRAVEL AT THE
CHECKPOINT IS SIMPLY
COMFORTABLE AND I. THAT COMMENT
AND I HOPE THAT WE DO FIND A
WAY TO GET FOR THOSE WHO WANT
TO HAVE A REAL LOOK AT THE-
FIRST. THEY HAVE THE EDUCATION
EVERYBODY. IS THE LAW. THE OPT
OUT DECISION THEY MADE BUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY HAS NO
THIS IS THE LAW BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WANT TO TURN ANYONE AWAY
WHERE AN S. NUMBERS ARE
CONCERNED BEING ONLY 16% YES IT
IS A SERIOUS IT. PROBLEM WHEN I
TAKE THE OF OUT OF MY. TO WE
HOPE THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES DO GET THE MESSAGE
SO THAT THEY CAN IF THEY WANT
THEY CAN BE IN COMPLIANCE IT
STARTS WITH LEADERSHIP LIKE AND
YOU IN AN INSTANT HIT. THAT
THAT THAT WOULD SIGNIFICAN THE
AROUND MOMENTO. WE NEED TO.
COME INTO THE NEW YEAR AS WELL
YES THANK YOU. WELL THANK YOU
MUCH FOR A- HELPING US FOCUS IN
ON HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE IS
DOUG. ALL OF FOR. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT COMES TO OUR
TRAVEL AND TOURISM I THINK THAT
THE MONEY THAT IS SPENT THE
STATE. TOURISTS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND HAS A RIPPLE
EFFECT THE IS FROM TEN TO THE
STATE TO THE TO THE OTHER. I'M
CERTAINLY FOR ALL THE. ON THE
DIET IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND. IN MY DISTRICT-
ENCOMPASSES THE ON THE SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS HOLLYWOOD SO
MANY OTHER ICONIC PLACES SAID-
IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
BECAUSE OF. ALL DROP IN. AND
NOT IN TOURISM THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE AN ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT
WILL UP THE POTENTIAL REASON.
POTENTIALLY RESOUND FOR QUITE.
SO AGAIN FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AT THE- FOR KING CUT OUT WITH
YOU. **** BUT GOING FORWARD. ON
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE OUR OUTRAGE
ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE FEEL FREE
ONE WITH MYSELF AND THE MEMBERS.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. YOU'RE
WELCOME SO WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO
THE PUBLIC COM I AM. THAT'S
GOING TO. COME TO MAKE CUTS TO
PLEASE FORWARD AND HE LOOKS TO
IT WILL HAND MICROPHONE DOWN TO.
I'D TELL US THAT YOU CAN BUY
COMMENT TWO THREE. SO WE JUST
HAVE ONE PERSON ONE AND. WHAT
YOU'RE STEP FORWARD SIR.
WELCOME MR KERNS WHO. IS YOUR
REPRESENTS MONICA TRAVEL AND
TOURISM. AND IT. TO ME BUT I
THINK FOR SOME REASON WANTED TO
SEE ME. ANOTHER IT'S BEEN A FEW
YEARS. WELCOME SIR. MY NAME IT
WOULD HAVE. NATIONAL CIVIL
LIBERTIES ORGANIZATION WHOSE
PRIORITY. THE FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT AND FREEDOM OF TRAVEL.
AS OUR IN OUR WRITTEN TWENTY
WOULD HAVE JUST GIVEN TO THE
EIGHT AND HAD PROVIDED
ELECTRONICALLY IN ADVANCE I
HOPE. HE HAS. ANY OF THE COSTS.
NATION OF THE LIP.
CALIFORNIA-DRIVERS-PAY-UNDERFUNDED-STATE-PATROL-PENSION.
REAL THE DEBATE AS WE WILL BE
REQUIRED IF CALIFORNIA. I. HOPE
YOU WILL DMV ABOUT THEIR PLANS
TEND. THE STATION IN THE SPECS
NATIONAL ID. SECOND THE DMB.
FOR IMPLEMENTATION CLAIMS.
ABOUT WHAT I DO REQUIRED BY THE
DIRECT DID BOTH WHAT THE STATE
HAS TED IN COURTING. THE TSA
RECORDS RELEASED IN RESPONSE
FRIEDMAN VINCE MAC REQUESTS
WHAT MADE WAS SURPRISED GIVEN
THE VEHEMENCE WITH WHICH HAVE
CLAIMED OTHERWISE. BUT IN FACT.
HAS BEEN NO LAW OR REGULATION
REQUIRES TRAVELERS TO SHOW. ANY
ID. AND THE RECORDS WE HAVE
OBTAINED LOGS AND KELLY. THAT
FROM THE TSA. THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHY WOULD I EVERY NIGHT
WE DID DISCUSS THOSE IN MORE
DETAIL IF YOU'D LIKE. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY IN THE FACE OF WHAT
IS IN ITS ESSENCE A ROLL THREAT
TO RESTRICT OF CALIFORNIANS TO
FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT AND
PARTICULARLY UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS. THE DMB HAS
CHOSEN TO BUDGET ONLY FOR HOW
TO CAPITULATE AND EVEN HOW TO
COLLABORATE IN THAT ATTACK ON
CALIFORNIANS RIGHTS RATHER THAN
AS OUR STATE HAS DONE IN OTHER
AREAS. PREPARING PLANNING AND
BUDGETING TO DEFEND THE RIGHTS
OF ANY CALIFORNIANS WHOSE
FREEDOM TO TRAVEL BY COMMON
CARRIER IS DENIED OR INFRINGED
BY FEDERAL ACTION. WE URGE YOU
TO BEGIN THE PLANNING AND
BUDGETING PROCESS AND TO
SCHEDULE FURTHER HEARINGS ABOUT
WHAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO
DEFEND RIGHTS IT'S RESIDENTS
AGAINST THIS FEDERAL ATTACK ON
THEIR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. WE
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS QUESTION FOR DETAIL ANY
OF YOU OR YOUR STAFF OR AT A
FUTURE HEARING. YOU HAVE SAID
AND I AGREE THE TURNING PEOPLE
AWAY AT CHECK POINTS ON IS
SIMPLY WRONG. AND YOU ALSO
SPOKEN MODERNIZING THE REPLY
IDEA. BEST WAY TO AVOID THE
PROBLEMS YOU HAVE DISCUSSED IS
TO WORK WITH YOUR FEDERAL
LEGISLATURES ONE. AMENDMENT.
THE REALIZE ACT WHICH IS ITS
REPEAL. WHAT ARE THE GOVERNMENT
RESULT. THE TWO ACTORS RIGHTS
BACK AT POINTS WE'LL LIKE
DEPEND SIGNIFICANT. IN WATER
THE DHS SO BEAR WITH THE STATE.
IS FULLY PREPARED TO DEFEND THE
RIGHT CALIFORNIA. TWO WITH
COMMIT TO CALL THE- GENERAL
THEIR PREPARATIONS TO DEFEND
CALIFORNIANS WHOSE RIGHTS ARE
INFRINGED SAY CHECKPOINTS OR DO
WE DID NOT PROCESS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL I'M NOT WE WILL
ADJOURN THE HEARING THANK YOU
ALL FOR ATTENDING